i i thought we talk about logic
okay that sounds logical
somehow we all know
about how to reason i mean we reason
with our young with our parents with our
partners and and then with our children
and so on so we and our bosses and
friends and
whatever
but
sometimes we want to be very precise
about
reasoning and this sort of precise form
of reasoning
is uh
realized in in in logic
is investigated understood
and presented in logic and this is also
sometimes quite important to not make uh
commit any fallacies to to to to adopt
wrong
kinds of reasoning so you really need
you really need to understand and study
the the rules of
of reasoning so one
of the things i'm doing when i teach
logic so i teach this in the second year
is i'm using a computer program a proof
assistant
called lean
and
lean
actually was developed uh at microsoft
research
by a guy leonardo de mora
who who also he he developed some
automatic
proof systems
uh he's very famous for that the theory
improver
but then he he he was also interested in
proof
assistance or
interactive proof systems
which which can
interact with automatic theory improving
and i will explain this a bit more later
i hope
but uh the main idea here is to have a
system you can sort of interact with or
an interactive proof system you you you
can you can
type in basically your proofs and the
proof system will check whether your
proof is okay
and
when i want to teach
logic to to students
i find this is extremely helpful because
otherwise it's very hard to say what is
really an exact acceptable argument yeah
i mean people
you give them some examples and then you
maybe ask for homework do this yeah and
then they do something which looks like
a proof yeah but it may you're not sure
whether they really understood this or
whether they just produce something
which which which i think
looks like a proof yeah and and proofs
can be can be very subtly wrong i mean
do you know the do you know the proof
that all horses have the same color
here's a proof it uses this idea of
induction so one horse has got the same
color right
and now you have any number of horses
and you you divide them into two groups
which overlap
at one horse here
and now by induction hypothesis for the
smaller
collection of horses you know that they
have all the same color
and the horse in the middle has the same
color so horses together has the same
color right so that's a proof that all
horses have the same color right
and this is wrong
yeah but these kind of proofs
they show up maybe more subtle sometimes
you prove something which is actually
correct but your proof is is flawed yeah
okay
so
so i think
for me the best way
to
to explain uh
logic and and to
to make it uh people to understand it is
to use
these these proof systems
now they have another purpose as well
because we can use them
and they are actually
used not everywhere but in some places
to verify
some systems which are either safety
critical or which are
hardware very frequently used or can be
quite inferior can be quite expensive
and so now some companies start to use
these proof systems
for applications here the best way to
learn it is by doing it and here so a
proof system like i'm using is like the
lean system which i'm using
is is extremely useful maybe i should
say a bit more about about lean which is
now also
used by the mathematicians
i mean first it was mainly used by
computer scientists and the
mathematicians are a bit conservative
you know they're not they don't really
want to change anything yeah
um
but actually there's this uh a guy in
imperial college kevin brothert and he
is really pushing this and he's using
also he's using lean also to teach
mathematics to the to the mathematics
undergraduate and he has recently given
a talk at the international mathematical
congress
where he has shown what they are doing
and is quite impressive because they
actually able now to to formalize very
recent results in mathematics using the
system
and and and do it with this proof system
and this is impressive because these
recent results they are like icebergs
yeah
there's lots of underwater
stuff lots of theorems that they need
here and they have done it all the way
down for very recent theorems
and
really leading edge mathematics which is
very very impressive
and and now uh their current project is
to formalize you know vermont's last
theorem which which says that
that x to the n plus y to the n equals z
to the n
has no solutions if n is greater than
two but for two we know that three two
three squared plus four squared equals
five squared here but but if it's more
than squared if it's cubed or anything
higher there's no solution and fermat
claimed
that he had a proof
but nobody believes this anymore but
recently a few years ago uh
mathematicians came up with the proof
and uh it's uh it's it's it's a proof
using
all of contemporary mathematics so it's
really really
really like a moon landing project to
formalize this and let's see whether
they whether they will able to do this
yeah before we do anything very exciting
like fermat's last theorem
that we're not doing today
what we start with is a bit like when
you do learn piano you have to play
scales right and and scales are a bit
boring but but you need to to learn them
to to how to move your fingers and in
logic
we do something like this we prove
propositional tautologies yeah
so what's a tautology
like
in the example tautology is like a
propositional uh expression which is
always true
okay
let's look at at my example here so i've
now launched lean actually i'm using
this visual studio code by microsoft
oh i should actually mention that lean
is is free so you can just download it
and i'm using lean three there's no new
version v4 okay so i i've done some
stuff there which i'm not going to
explain but here is is my uh
tautology i want to show so let me
explain this what does it say
i say
if p implies q
then not q implies not p
so this l there means implies so if then
and this little hook means not and error
means implies and here we could we could
put some extra brackets in to make it
more clear you know then unnecessary
so here i'm saying if p then q then
if not q then not p so this is a
tautology so being a tautology means
whatever we plug in for p and q
it's always true
but actually i find when i explain it i
find it useful to think of some concrete
examples
so let's say p is
the sun shines in cube you go to the zoo
yeah and now i tell my my my children
if the sun shines then we go to the zoo
the consequence of this is
if you don't go to the zoo
then the sun doesn't shine yeah and you
have to think for a moment about this
yeah why this is actually true if i say
if the sunshine then we go to the zoo
and we don't go to the zoo
then obviously the only possible
situation is that the sun doesn't shine
you're a child
you're not only for a child i mean what
is not true
is if the sunshine we go to the zoo
does not imply if the sun doesn't shine
we don't go to the zoo because it didn't
see anything
what happens if the sun doesn't shine so
that would be a fallacy yeah okay but if
you if you if you turn it around it's
it's it's correct all right and how can
we see it's a tautology
how can we see it what do you say well
can you factor out those knots
yeah you want to have some algebra here
you have to apply some algebra okay
that's one way it feels like
but people usually have seen truth
tables right okay so that's yet another
way uh to to to check uh propositional
tautologies yeah
but that's not what i'm uh going to do
today because actually truth tables are
quite okay for
propositional logic but when you move on
to predicate logic and you have
quantifiers when you talk about our
numbers or lists
to do with programs then truth tables
are not very helpful
so what we are going to do instead we
are going to look at the proof okay
we're going to prove this interactively
and here i said sorry but sorry means
i'm sorry i haven't yet provided a proof
here
and if i go here into the video into the
beginning of this of this proof block
i am i'm seeing here some uh uh
something
uh it says there's a symbol here is
called a turnstile and that's what i
want to prove right this is the
statement i want to prove and it has
removed my brackets because they're not
really necessary so lean's done that for
you then yeah yeah if i
if i go somewhere else nothing is
visible but if i go here then it tells
me okay this is your current proof state
you know so how do i prove now i have to
prove an implication so how do i have to
prove if this is the case then this is
the case so how do i prove an
application and the rule how to prove an
application is very simple
i use assume i assume
the the left hand side
and which i call p q and i have to prove
the right hand side
let me
go on so what happened now
is
this proof state has changed i i have to
prove only the conclusion not q implies
not p
but i have an assumption now
namely that p implies q
and again i have to prove an implication
not q implies not p
now we know already how to prove an
application
namely we assume
the left hand side
and we prove the right hand side so now
assuming not q to prove not p okay so
assume
i call it nq
and what happens is now that i have
another assumption not q
and i still have to prove not p
so now we have to understand what
negation is right so i have used
implication now we have to use negation
now let me make a comment here
in
in lean
negation
is also an implication it says not p
means p
implies false so how can we understand
this false is a bit of a tricky thing to
explain
and my explanation for false is
pigs have wings if i want to say not p
then i see if p then pigs have wings
yeah and that means not p right yeah yes
if if you ask a girl do you want to
marry me and she is if i marry you then
pigs have wings that means no right yeah
yeah yeah
yeah pigs might fly yes it's not really
okay so that's the idea that's just an
implication so now in this situation we
are here
we want to prove not p
but it really means p implies false
so all we have to do
we have to assume p
and then we have to try to prove that
pigs have been inside
okay
so you see now you have the assumption p
and i have to pull forwards
so how can i put false how can i prove
that pigs have wings
now
actually there's one way because i have
an assumption called not q
and not q means if q then pigs have
wings right
so i want to prove pigs have wings and i
have audio assumption which says
if q then pixel wings
so now i'm uh i'm using this so this
time i'm using a different tactic
i'm using
apply
and apply
enqueue
and what's happening
is now i have to prove q because i
wanted to prove
if q
i mean i i used if q then picks
picks up wings
now
i'm use this now i'm down to proving q
and again how can i prove q
i look at my assumption there's one
assumption which says if p is in q i can
use this and could use proving q to
proving p
okay let me just do this
so i say apply
pq
pq
and now what happens is
i have to prove p
because
if p's and q
i want to prove q now i'm down to
proving just p yeah
but that's very easy because uh i i i
already know p i have an assumption p
and i can just say exact
p
and goals accomplished i get a firework
and i can get rid of my soy
because
i have done the whole pool so that's an
example of a very simple proof
this is one of these warm-up exercises
to prove these propositional uh
tautologies
uh
which
which are as as
reasoning right
we learn things like okay if you want to
prove not q implies not p
then
you
you can you can you can prove p implies
q
okay
now this is a very simple uh
very simple
tautology and you think why do i have to
invest all this hard work
to do this
and the answer is you don't so lean has
a built-in prover which can uh which can
which can automatically grow very simple
propositions now if i want to teach
people how to learn proofs then they're
not allowed to use it
yeah yeah yeah it's like cheating but i
wanted to show something
actually uh
what's the proof for lean so here you
just used example but let me give this a
name
it's called a theorem
p1
okay
so i've
we now prove the theorem and let's print
the theorem okay or print the proofs
actually
okay
so here we see the proof in lean and
this is like a it's actually a
functional program you see the lambda
here so it's a proof it's a functional
program but i don't have to write this
program instead i can use these tactics
and the clever tactics is it auto
does be the same thing
because
it produces also a proof object
if you see so p2 is the automatic pool
and it basically produces the same proof
as i have produced by hand yeah so
but the point here is even if i use
these these automatic tactics they still
could use the proof yeah and this is the
idea of of lean is always safe yeah
you can extend it you can write very
clever tactics but you always have to
give
evidence for this
okay
and i wanted to to
to finish this part with a little uh
challenge to prove that the following is
a tautology it cannot be that p if and
only if not p so here's this if and only
if
uh is defined and it just means uh
logical equivalence p implies not p and
not p implies p so
it's just defined as implication in both
directions yeah and we want to show that
this is not the case now this turns out
this is actually not not so easy to do i
mean it's
clear that it cannot be that the
proposition is equivalent to its own
negation right but to actually prove
this is a bit of a challenge now if i
use it auto
it proves it yeah
it's very happy but the challenge is to
prove it without it it auto
tautologies in mean which are
a bit like doing the scales on the piano
but now we want to play a little song a
very simple song i mean nothing
complicated we can categorically say
that if we gave that to a person they
would say there's a remote control in
that image and some noise